foreign  example  we haven't received any formal documents  from the community or from the  authorities so the first request we have  is to have a formal legitimate  document to say that okay you are in  high risk area you have to do quarantine  if not then they should not a lock down  the mentor and B if anybody has any  emergencies please let us now  from them  all right  so I think what we have got today is  that so far there is no official  announcement about this lockdown so I  think for me I'm not a challenger to you  know all kinds of authority but I went  out because nobody just stopped me so I  went out and I think I will follow all  the so-called quarantine Continentals uh  by the government and to further notice  once this community is recognized at  high risk  oh  yeah  that's cool we're free to go